previously on TV sins I promise not a
drop of alcohol is gonna touch these
lips tonight the creators of Comedy
Central's South Park Comedy Central's
South Park hi I'm Jane Parker I was
promised shoddy animation and this is
some of the most realistic animation
I've ever seen the fact that they could
do this kind of CG 20 years ago and
still chose to go with the crude paper
cutouts is unconscionable okay switching
the dog out for a completely different
breed is pretty hilarious but if I've
learned anything from the sin haters out
there you most certainly aren't allowed
to purposely draw your audience by
making mistakes even if it's comedic why
because damn us all to hell as well so
sit back relax and enjoy Cartman gets an
anal probe roll commercials can I get a
ruling on rolling commercials when an
intro purposely mentions the episodes
title in an exaggerated parody yes yes
we are clear to roll the commercials no
matter how humorous the reading might be
it's still reading humble folks without
temptation I mean you can say the
purposely awful lyrics to the theme song
or a part of the jokes all you want but
at some point a little effort might be a
pleasant surprise
I realize everyone will say the
animation style is part of the show's
charm and after 300 episodes and
Counting it's hard to argue but it's
still the animation and I'm a dip so
based on how much winter where the kids
have on I think the bigger issue is that
Ike is about to die a slow and very very
cold death this is not the dark well
that couldn't have shot day for night
here I love that the show's pilot pays
homage to one of my favorite movies Jim
Cameron's visitors sponge that's when
they put this big metal hoop would you
up your butt Hoopa joke you children
watch that fat boy now he could be on
the alien control very few t-shirts only
have printing on the back unless of
course you'd need a surprise message
when someone turns around
[Applause]
excited even in something is purposely
crass as South Park basic fart joke it's
still the basic fart joke not sure what
is less believable here that there's
aliens or that they have any fresh hay
in the winter no party going on
unfortunately for large stretches of the
episode officer Barbrady is absolutely
correct discovered America and was the
Indians best friend he helped the
Indians win their war against Frederick
Douglass and freed the Hebrews from
Napoleon Wikipedia considering mr.
garrison and a lot of the kids don't
have coats and a hat and they're inside
where Cartman and Cruz still dressed
like brandy from a Christmas Story sure
fine but you aren't exactly at a people
station now are you so maybe need to
look inside yourself and check on why
you decided to park your locomotive in a
pasture where the cows could line up in
the first place an actual question posed
by Trey Parker and Matt Stone and South
Park was born this poster has changed
fonts in the last 30 seconds I mean you
say you but then you purposely walk
right through it I'm calling barf
mannequins this frame contains the
animators hand is this on purpose if so
why wouldn't it be easy to fix is it a
joke sometimes I feel like when you make
something that is occasionally
intentionally inaccurate or wrong you're
just doing it so that no one will call
you out on your actual mistakes well at
least I've heard people do that if this
vegetable medley option isn't Larry the
Cucumber singing a combination of his
favorite silly songs I'm calling bullsh
Jim continues to ignore the fact that
what they continued flaming flatulence
and now a full case of hemorrhoids
Cartman's pants would be completely
destroyed by now chef must be one of
those quick-change artists cuz second to
no he was wearing an apron with his name
and lowercase letters and no it's
uppercase and it keeps switching from
shot to shot also I would immediately
buy tickets to the chef quick-change
show cuz HB lit Tom nee know how to
aesthetically arrange faces but he is a
complete [ __ ] when it comes to sign
placement every Comedy Central execs
question after viewing the pilot episode
made its way into the script
hard enough to take a sin off for the
start of one of the best running gags of
all time
oh my god city you bastards
well Cartman you're in a show called
South Park when the creators that show
think ass humorous it's perched atop
Maslow's hierarchy of laws so you best
get used to it but I've learned
something today then having a little
brother is a pretty special thing barely
Kyle's parents don't feel the same since
there has been no show parental concern
in regards to Mike being gone all day
swear bleeps
how about for business Hagrid I see you
Adam no what's a dildo its Japanese for
nunchucks
[Music]
[Music]
personation of David Caruso's career